you're in a relationship that doesn't
feel good to you but yeah you wake up
every morning and you do your best to
put on a show to preserve that
relationship so you tell your partner
certain things you deprive yourself of
your own needs you say things that are
in contradiction to your truth in order
to just keep that going so what are we
actually doing at the end of the day we
are lying to ourselves keeping ourselves
in the dark in order to maintain some
external reality that we think is going
to suit us but does it really usually
that ends up resulting in anxiety and
depression and suppressed feelings and
personal mistrust and in quieting our
inner voice because we don't believe
that it deserves to be heard when we're
in such dramatic contrast to our higher
self's awareness and our own personal
truth that the system goes
anxiety is telling us that we need to
pay attention to ourselves and yet we
see it and we try to silence it even
more we think of anxiety as something
that we need to just run away from but
it's similar to pain it's a reality that
means you need to listen more to
yourself a lot of people approach pain
in that way too they think that if I'm
in pain you know I need to try to shut
those feelings down try to do something
to run away from myself when in truth
it's the exact opposite thing it's your
self-consciousness of your internal
system begging you for attention wanting
recognition wanting you to actually go
within and accept those feelings and
somatic experiences but what do we often
do we just keep going into the world and
try to distract ourselves we want to try
the next thing to run away from our own
truth and everything we know to be real
for us deep down that's the most
degrading thing we can do
well the last time it happened I
basically
re responded within it probably was
discomfort for like 30 or 40 minutes and
then I ended up sending a message being
like um I'm having like a somatic
experience my body is freaking out I
know it's not I I said it doesn't feel
like mine I don't know what's going is
something going on is there information
in the field coming to me that is not
yet in my conscious awareness that lands
in the subconscious or in the energy
body that tells me something that is not
yet arrived up here in the brain well
really they're all entangled right your
soul your heart's Consciousness your
higher self that knowing that's in the
field basically you know who you are at
your core you could feel that by
connecting to Your Heart by just being
with yourself feeling that information
but it's also something that is in the
field because you could say that in the
holographic field around us there exists
really a true version of us the soul
that is non-local so you could be
picking up that information right as
you're entangling with your higher self
that's coming through intuition through
subtle cues which a lot of people wonder
what's the difference between then fear
and intuition if intuition can come in
the form of fear when we feel like we're
out of alignment with our higher self
so that's something to really look for
too because fear in the mind is usually
the opposite of intuition but something
that feels like fear because when you're
in your heart you feel out of alignment
with something you're dealing with
externally could be the intuitive cue
you need to go back within and connect
to that source of Truth which is either
internal or you could say external but
not relating to the people around you
that are you know trying to get you out
of alignment so this is really a
question of whether or not we want to
come back home and know who we are and
do what's right for us to connect with
that frequency of just pure integrity
and and Truth this seems like the answer
for everybody would be yes right I feel
like everyone would say I want to know
the truth I mean I don't think
everyone's prepared to deal with what
that means but I think everyone would so
what blocks that like what is it that
doesn't allow someone to step into a
deeper knowing and sense of Truth and
sense of self it would be the harsh
reality that everything that you're
experiencing now is due to you depriving
yourself of that truth once you step
into the truth you have to be accepting
of everything that you've done that is
in opposition to it
and so we go into this cognitive
dissonance State we go into the state
that we have to now be responsible for
everything in our reality that we
dislike and we have to take ownership
over these parts of us that we've kept
in the dark and we've denied Our Truth
which turns into our shadow and it turns
into the repression of all the emotions
that really are deep down telling us
what our personal truth is saying and so
externally speaking when it comes to
things happening in the world which we
often you know turn our attention away
from the same thing holds true we don't
want to see the reality because that
would mean accepting everything that is
also teaching us the deeper lessons
about ourselves
and we don't want to harmonize because
that means having to reconcile the parts
of us that we have not seen we have not
understood and so this is what you know
makes people go into these repeating
cycles of constantly manifesting the
same situations dealing with the
expression of their Shadow because
they're all the time just trying to
deprive themselves of that truth and
it's easier for people to sort of live a
lie than to look in the mirror and to
figure out what is it that's causing the
expression of these things that I
dislike
but then that means not trying to run
away from them anymore
so to truly embody the truth means
having to meet everything that you've
been wanting to suppress it's wanting to
see everything in your reality as an
expression of you which could be the
most difficult part because we want to
say that you know certain things we're
not responsible for some things are just
you know part of suffering and the
universe's test for us it's a matter of
how do we respond to that and do we want
to respond truthfully or keep ourselves
in this Loop of just believing that the
universe is working against us because
truthfully might mean the end of a
relationship the end of a friendship the
end of a job the end of where you live
the end of how you go about your life
certain habits and hobbies you have and
you know as I say so often and I had to
say to myself in the past is that your
new life is going to cost you your old
one you know exactly and and that's a
hard thing for people to and I think
there's there's some there's a deep
attachment that people have to I can
feel it in the energy of like
um like Joe dispenza's book title like
breaking the habit of being yourself but
in this sort of uh changing of
Personality or like becoming someone
different it's like there's a real
loyalty to the Persona that someone has
created for themselves that they don't
want to abandon there's like a certain
um they feel like that's the wrong thing
that that's not somebody loving them
just the way they are or they feel like
it is somehow the like just not um like
that that it's an abandoning of the
personality
right it's a coping mechanism really
it's a defense mechanism oh kind of like
during Coco's story they tell you to go
like oh no this is who you are right
which is the most pervasive image of who
we are we start to have a love affair
with this ego because we think that it's
what we need to sustain our sense of
self because what's really what's true
deep down if we keep going deeper and
deeper past those layers of falsity and
you know self-image things that we
fabricate in order to believe that that
is who we are is a totally fluid essence
at the core of it is no Essence at all I
mean everything is just pure energy pure
potentiality pure Consciousness so when
it comes down to that infinite potential
of ourselves we want to fragment it we
want to bring it into some kind of
constructs that we believe make us more
relatable more appreciable more loved
all the while this is something that we
developed when we were still so young
that we didn't have a sense of identity
and so we learned to take these mental
constructs and turn them into ego
constructs and you're so right like
personality is something that could be
completely fluid except we don't want
that to be because we think that it's
unsafe to go into the world in a fluid
way is there anything inherent or is
this whole thing transitory and we can
shift and transcend it into something
completely different
called The Human Experience
right the inherent nature of it is that
we were born into a third dimensional
construct where we believe that we need
to be submitting to this construct
and so when we get into this virtual
sense of you know wanting to transcend
wanting to Enlighten wanting to become
the fifth dimensional Consciousness we
can come into an awareness of what it
means to live outside of the box outside
of the Matrix Game which means learning
to see outside of the program but to
transcend that isn't necessarily to not
exist within it so for asanas we're here
we're existing within the Matrix right
within the third dimensional reality so
what our Consciousness knows is that
there's constantly these boundaries that
we're up against we're up against
boundaries of time which your mind can
recognize but we know that time is also
transcendental in nature but we have to
learn how to work with those constructs
just like we have to learn to integrate
Duality Duality is a construct within
the third dimensional Consciousness we
know that everything has a plus and
minus positive negative charge right
that's not something that we can
transcend if we know love we're also
going to know pain if we know sadness
we're also going to know happiness we
have to learn to experience and love
that balance so that's inherent to us
but there is something very pervasive
too being within the Matrix
and wanting to conform to it that is
what the collective mind tends to do
people tend to be as one with the herd
they want to do the same thing that
everybody else does there's this
mentality that you know we need to
believe what everyone else believes and
so it's very difficult to learn how to
transcend when we look around everyone's
doing a certain thing and we can see
this Collective Consciousness playing
into all historic Trends everything from
you know fashion to food to the latest
diet to exercise Trends people are
constantly playing into some Trend
created by someone who wants us to think
and feel in a certain way and when we
don't doubt that we're always going to
be doing what everyone else does in The
Matrix playing a game fulfilling some
role and not really knowing who we are
because we're just adapting to the
concept of life within the Matrix
when we start to recognize that this is
the Matrix Game and we're a unique
individual that really exists outside of
the Matrix we were born to come into
here to recognize that this is what's
happening but really all the world's a
stage for us to recognize who we are and
learn what role do we really want to
embody is it this person who is just
operating by a script written by
somebody else or perhaps or with someone
who can recognize this game for what it
is and learn to operate outside of it so
when we do that when we step into that
mentality of true awareness and
Awakening then there becomes a reality
where we exist outside of The Matrix
and all of these disorders and different
issues that people are dealing with are
really just aspects of you not knowing
that you don't have to conform to The
Matrix which means you don't have to
conform to your past you don't have to
conform to what your mind tells you you
are you don't have to look to the media
and believe everything that you were
told you can really start to believe
that you are a free Sovereign being
governed by the universal one and you
can take that Consciousness into a
completely new experience and just start
to play with it and existing in that
reality where you are the Mind yours one
with the cosmic mind and a higher
intelligence brings you this truth that
really there is no attachment other than
what you decide to attach yourself to
and that's a game changer because then
we can operate with love with freedom
with virtue and dignity and really know
that we are the creator of this
experience so why not make it the most
fluid harmonious experience that we can
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen